[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco
aquí en europa y la gestión que está
haciendo el bloque europeo de la guerra
de ucrania con múltiples frentes
abiertos como la soberanía energética la
europa de la defensa o también la
gestión de la crisis de refugiados nos
acompañan en este estudio luís rivas ex
corresponsal en moscú bienvenido luís
gracias patricia páez es periodista
especializada en temas de migración es
bienvenida a patricia y mário genial
sanín profesora de economía experta en
energía es bienvenida y también en
dúplex desde bruselas nuestra
corresponsal esther herrera buenos días
a
europa en la guerra de ucrania hoy
nuestro asunto en primera plana
[Música]
los 27 países de la unión europea se han
reunido en versalles bajo la presidencia
de turno de manuel macrón con el
escenario de la guerra de ucrania
dejando a su paso múltiples desafíos
para el bloque y la pregunta de si
europa saldrá fortalecida de esta guerra
o todo lo contrario cuestiones como la
soberanía energética o la gestión de la
gran cantidad de refugiados con una
cifra que avanza hacia los 3 millones de
ucranianos aparecen como cruciales más
complicada aún será la necesidad de una
defensa común del bloque la inversión de
putin ha puesto sobre la mesa de la
unión cuestiones básicas para su pura
supervivencia que hoy vamos a analizar
en este programa antes repasemos algunas
portadas que nos deja la prensa algunas
como ésta de the economics no hace falta
ni que la comentemos con la bandera de
ucrania manchada de sangre y sin ningún
texto la revista lux habla del balanceo
del mundo por esta guerra y habla de una
nueva era geopolítica the times las
familias que huyen para salvar sus vidas
de ucrania el impacto de la guerra de
rusia contra ucrania va a tener
importantes consecuencias a todos los
niveles en la economía ya las estamos
viendo en los precios de la energía en
la cantidad de refugiados en nuestra
defensa la primera pregunta que les
quiero formar a los tres somos
conscientes luís de la magnitud de las
consecuencias que esta guerra va a tener
para el futuro de europa yo creo que
todavía no y por los dos razones primero
porque la emoción que transmiten las
imágenes
está todavía lo que más afecta a la
gente en segundo lugar porque los
políticos están utilizando también estas
imágenes para justificar unos ajustes
económicos que estaban antes incluso
previstos que la guerra y yo creo que no
somos conscientes todavía o la mayoría
no es consciente porque lo malo badeni
después con las consecuencias económicas
patricio sí bueno en mi caso yo creo que
no del todo porque siempre se ha visto
la guerra como lejos de europa siempre
he visto que está más allá de nuestras
fronteras y a mí me parece que en
realidad las guerras sin ninguna cas
tras catástrofes distingue algún sitio
geográfico entonces en ese caso la
sociedad va a tener bastante dificultad
de poder
aceptar que van a traer muchos problemas
no estas cosas de la guerra que estamos
hablando del mayor éxodo desde la
segunda guerra algo impensable
maría eugenia las consecuencias
económicas como decía luis van a ser
importantes y ya estamos viendo
en los precios de los carburantes que
tienen grandísima vuelta y volatilidad
han sido multiplicado por tres en el
caso del gas esto no va a parar así tan
fácilmente y son consecuencias que
deberíamos empezar a pensar porque
alguien la va a tener que pagar y es el
contribuyente europeo
quien se verán más impactados
vamos a ir preguntando a nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas esther herrera
por cada uno de estos desafíos que la
guerra en ucrania abre en europa esther
habrá una política ordenada de acogida
de refugiados con todos los países
coordinados el hecho de que se haya
activado esta ley conocida como
directiva europea de protección temporal
es un hito se va a producir de forma más
ordenada todo apunta a que al menos lo
será más que la crisis de refugiados en
2015 2016 se han dado consignas de cómo
se debe gestionar la acogida la ayuda
humanitaria está siendo extraordinaria y
luego el hecho de que tengan esta
protección automática angelita mucho el
proceso no es como antes que se debe ir
caso por caso
a estudiar cada una de las solicitudes
de asilo es un proceso muy largo sino es
una cuestión controvertida el hecho de
que esta directiva temporal que se hizo
ya hace 20 años nada nadie la quisiera
aplicar ni con la guerra en estiria o
con los refugiados afganos 300 que
buscan ya es frontera con países como
polonia hungría y eslovaquia justamente
los tres países que más se opusieron a
la acogida de refugiados sirios y una de
las cosas que siempre alegraban era su
lejanía por la religión y también por el
idioma una muestra de que era racismo y
por lo tanto las dudas que podían tener
estos países ya no las tienen con los
ucranianos porque muchas personas y la
población misma puede pensar es que son
como nosotros son europeos abran nuestra
lengua y tienen nuestra misma religión
es doloroso pero hay una enorme
diferencia entre una crisis y la otra y
dudo que las tensiones que se vivieron
en 2015 entre los países se viva con
ésta
gracias a esther patricia pareces
experta en temas de migración es
patricia qué retos se van a encontrar
los países los países de acogida donde
están llegando los refugiados a corto y
medio plazo bueno no había existen
diversos retos en principio son personas
que vienen con de haber vivido de estar
viviendo a carne propia lo que es una
guerra así que van a venir con muchos
traumas van a vivir van a venir de
haberse separado de sus familias
entonces el primer reto vendría a ser
psicológico pero hay algo que quisiera
destacar sobre lo que ha dicho la
corresponsal yo creo que no existe en
realidad una diferencia en cuanto de las
crisis en realidad lo que aquí se ve es
que la unión europea está actuando de
manera conjunta con una voluntad
política sobre la acogida de los
refugiados y en realidad esto ha sido y
sin pensar que iba a venir la guerra es
decir se ha sido en ningún momento ser
específico que ha sido sin importar la
religión sin importar el país entonces
estamos viendo que europa en realidad
tiene la capacidad de poder responder a
una gran
flujo migratorio claro que la tienes sí
pero yo creo que
entiendo que se refiere a que el hecho
de que sean refugiados provenientes del
suelo europeo quizá facilite mucho la
acogida ante opiniones públicas en
países donde la extrema derecha si en su
momento pues un problema con los
refugiados sirios y con otro tipo es
decir para que se me entienda el
lenguaje un poco que sean rubitos y
blancos da menos problemas ante ciertas
opiniones públicas hablando un poco
claro pero también hay otra cosa los
refugiados sirios hay que tener en
cuenta el contexto el contexto era una
una serie de atentados también
islamistas en europa eso yo nos dio
justificación pero también que tiene en
cuenta ese contexto en los ucranianos
no son sospechosos de haber entonces no
hay esa esa sensación es la ponen
publicaron y yo creo que también hay
otra cosa que tener en cuenta también
que es más es más lógica hay una
cercanía física y una cercanía cultural
también por poner un ejemplo no es una
cuestión de religión o tal es que yo me
siento como español más próximo a un
colombiano que a un sueco
y un colombiano que sea indígena negro o
blanco me siento culturalmente más
cercano entonces que un noruego entonces
también hay que tenerlo en cuenta
también en cuanto al racismo el racismo
yo lo veo también en sorprendentemente
en algunos periodistas
periodistas de la cnn y periodistas de
algunas cadenas francesas que
precisamente son ellos los que han dicho
es que no estamos tratando con personas
como sirios o como como africanos que
estamos hablando de gente como nosotros
o sea son los propios periodistas
algunos periodistas los que no como
crítica sino como insistiendo en ello
para decir tenemos que ayudarles más
bueno parece que el tema de los
refugiados hay cierta unidad en el
bloque europeo en esta ocasión no lo es
tanto en otras cuestiones como en el
tema energético por algunas dependencias
la debilidad del sistema energético en
europa ya era una verdad sabida amar y
eugenia
pero la guerra quizá deja al descubierto
la gravedad del problema no sé si ese
problema le tendríamos que poner el
nombre de dependencia yo creo que le
tendremos que poner el nombre de
interdependencia
porque europa gasta 200.000 millones de
euros al año en hidrocarburos rusos eso
es cuatro veces lo que gasta rusia en
gasto militar
entonces
rusia en alguna vez la mitad de las
exportaciones rusas más o menos más del
15% del pib ruso o sea rusa depende de
este ingreso y nosotros o sea europa
depende de los hidrocarburos rusos en
particular el gas ruso es cien por
ciento del gas finlandés 80 por ciento
del gas austríaco 55 tú lo decías carlos
del gas alemán y entonces en el caso de
francia es un poco menos
pero es muy complicado hacer suplirlo
directamente y además tenemos un mercado
europeo hemos hemos ido hacia una hace
un mercado energético europeo y entonces
en si no regulamos ese mercado
efectivamente en los los incrementos en
los precios nos afectan a todos porque
el precio es el que define al margen y
no tanto en la cantidad exacta le vamos
a preguntar por la soberanía energética
a nuestra corresponsal porque es una
cuestión que se antoja fundamental para
el futuro de europa esther la no
dependencia de rusia como pretende
resolver bruselas está qué alternativas
vislumbra tanto a corto medio y largo
plazo como europa puede sustituir al gas
ruso como comentaba maría eugenia con
países tan dependientes como alemania o
austria es una cuestión increíblemente
complicada esta semana el propio
vicepresidente de la comisión europea
frans timmermans decía que va a ser
terriblemente complicado pero que hay
que hacerlo la comisión europea confía
en que se reduzcan dos tercios la
dependencia del gas ruso de aquí a
finales de año diversificando más sus
proveedores por ejemplo con noruega y
argelia también más gas natural licuado
proveniente de qatar de eeuu y aumentar
las renovables y el hidrógeno renovable
pero la misma unión europea sabe que lo
complicado es el invierno que viene por
ello quiere empezar ya a prepararse para
que las reservas antes de que empiece el
frío estén al 90 por ciento del sobre de
su almacenaje pero esto tendrá unos
costes indudables el gas licuado es
mucho más caro e implica también un
esclarecimiento por el transporte
bruselas confía que a corto plazo se
tenga en cuenta a socios más fiables que
rusia aunque no se quiere
completo cortar la relación porque como
decía alemania y austria dependen mucho
del gas pero a largo plazo se quiere
confiar en el aumento de las renovables
y muchos países piensan que tampoco es
tan mala idea a ser confiando en la
energía nuclear vemos la apuesta
clarísima que hace francia y esta semana
a bélgica ya ha dicho que va a
replantearse su apuesta por cerrar las
nucleares en dos años y quizás diga
alargar más la vida de sus centrales
alternativas como el gas natural líquido
la diversificación de proveedores o
incluso que se empieza hoy lo hemos
empezado a ir esta semana concienciar al
ciudadano de bajar al consumo si esto
esto esto es lo que se aproxima también
una conciencia le se dice muy
tímidamente y se decía además que en una
sociedad de confort como la europea que
si una sociedad de confort en la que hay
muchos pobres también
porque lo que estamos viviendo algunos
políticos algunos especialistas de
de expertos en energía es decir bueno
tenemos que hacer un esfuerzo y la gente
tiene que bajar un grado la temperatura
de su casa y hay incluso más más
divertido todavía para mí
entre comillas es decir las familias
tienen que abandonar su casa un día
y vivir con sus con sus familiares con
sus primos que esto es una tomadura de
pelo
europa no es soberana ni económicamente
ni energéticamente perdón ni de defensa
como se está hablando ahora los
políticos están haciendo en general una
serie de promesas que son inviables a
final de año pero que mario gen ya lo
conoce mucho mejor que yo pero no hay
infraestructuras para una alternativa de
llegada de 10 decorar burós ni de
petróleo y de gas todavía no existe eso
vamos a hacer una breve pausa si me lo
permites en este punto louis lo que pasa
que es que a lo mejor no nos queda otra
con la que o con la que tenemos ligada
hacemos una cosa volvemos enseguida
en la cee del cono sur a norte américa
de los andes' a centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
porque la historia se escribe día a día
porque la actualidad no espera la
información dondequiera que esté en
cualquier circunstancia
todos los temas para entender el mundo
para imaginar el mundo
france24 una mirada diferente
liberté égalité actually team
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de cómo europa está gestionando
la guerra de ucrania y las consecuencias
que va a tener para el bloque lo hacemos
con la economista maría eugenia sanín
luís rivas es corresponsal en moscú
patricia páez periodista especializado
en temas de migraciones y en dúplex
desde bruselas nuestra corresponsal
esther herrera estábamos hablando del
acto bueno de la claridad de nuestros
dirigentes respecto a las consecuencias
que va a provocar esta guerra en europa
a todos los niveles a nivel energético a
nivel de la cris de los refugiados a
nivel de la defensa y estamos hablando
de lo que estamos dispuestos también
quizá a sacrificar en nuestras
sociedades como ciudadanos por ejemplo
con el tema de la energía en la eugenia
si la cuestión es que vamos a tener que
hacer un sacrificio y un esfuerzo en
invertir en diversificar como decía el
corresponsal pero todo esto supone este
propone costes y en versace se están
hablando actualmente de dos costes que
son a la vez defensa e independencia
energética entonces el coste lo vamos a
tener que pagar en el corto y mediano
plazo
vamos a tener que encontrar sustitutos a
ese gas y más en el mediano o largo
plazo para lograr una verdadera
independencia para no cambiar una
dependencia por otra dependencia vamos a
tener que invertir fuertemente en
vectores energéticos es decir en
hidrógeno verde y en alguna medida en
baterías porque sabemos que las
renovables son intermitentes entonces
aunque aumentemos muchísimo masivamente
las renovables necesitamos y la buena
noticia es que en europa tenemos
empresas que son punteras en el know-how
de cómo
lograr este inversiones y
masivas en hidrógeno verde por ejemplo
entonces tenemos que dado que el gasto
lo tenemos que hacer de todas maneras la
idea es en el mediano y largo plazo
apuntar a lo que realmente nos conduzca
a una independencia energética
y luego esto se traduce también en los
precios estamos viendo los precios de la
energía completamente desbocados se está
comentando en bruselas de que esa
propuesta de españa de que por fin haya
una estrategia concreta con propuestas
concretas
los precios de la energía y que se
apruebe en el consejo ordinario del 24 y
25 en bruselas nos vamos a ver esas
propuestas concretas en los próximos
días o quizás es que no queda otra en
realidad es muy interesante lo que
planteas carlos porque actualmente en la
factura de gas en francia por ejemplo
está limitada hasta final de junio y
entonces ese límite lo paga el
contribuyente francés mientras que si
desde europa se coordina una regulación
del mercado del gas esa es la cosa no
pagamos los contribuyentes sino que paga
se reparte un poco vamos a pagar los
contribuyentes pero un poco van a pagar
los
beneficios de las grandes ensayos hay
una mutualización mayor y esa es la
clave que quiere que quiere ponerse
ahora encima de la mesa en el tema de
los precios subir signo si quieres
añadir algo más a esto si yo estoy
completamente de acuerdo con lo que
decía mario genia pero centrando más en
el ciudadano ciudadanox y yo creo que la
crisis económica en europa y en varios
países europeos ya existía antes de la
guerra
ahora mismo y entonces a lo que hay que
ver es cómo es el gobierno
va a gestionar
esa crisis que viene y convencer sobre
todo a los ciudadanos de que hay que
pagar por ucrania vamos a decirlo
claramente es que hay muchos ciudadanos
europeos que van a estar dispuestos
primero que se les digan
usted va a pagar mucho más por esto y
esto lo hacemos por ucrania y
estamos seguros de que los seleccionados
sobre per van a decir vale voy a
sacrificar por ucrania yo no lo veo tan
claro exacto y sobre todo a la hora de
pagar y sobre todo en cierto en ciertas
cuestiones como las que está numerado
porque parece la diferencia que el tema
de los refugiados sí que está siendo
acogido por las opiniones públicas y en
esa cuestión sí que los dirigentes están
siendo lo tienen más fácil en esta
ocasión parece que en otras como el
coste que nos bancos nos va a costar
todo esto no es tan fácil no en realidad
lo que yo pienso es que lo que ha
facilitado la acogida de refugiados
ucranianos es el despertar de la
solidaridad de la conciencia de que son
seres humanos que están pidiendo auxilio
que están huyendo de una guerra y que
necesitan una ayuda y que no hay razones
por las que tendríamos que negarles esta
ayuda además estamos comprometidos por
las normas internacionales de dar asilo
a estas personas que están huyendo de un
conflicto
creo que en este caso europa la
comunidad europea tiene la capacidad de
poder responder y lo estamos viendo
ahora la rapidez pero lamentablemente
las políticas y la solidaridad de tantos
europeos que están ahora mismo
trabajando en la frontera de polonia con
ucrania
voluntariamente que se han ido a
repartir comida es impresionante gente
que se coge un coche desde españa y va
por allí son los verdaderos euros a los
que a veces aplaudimos desde el sofá de
casa tranquilamente o haciendo un clic
como activismo a veces hay que decirlo
no hay gente que va que no esté en casa
con el twitter diciendo que bien si no
es que hay gente que va solamente su
broma louis sí como especie claro es eso
también pero tenemos que tomar en cuenta
que las políticas migratorias
actualmente en europa son políticas
realmente que son racistas y
discriminatorias y es por ello que ahora
se está actuando o sea se ha esperado
que llegue esta guerra en ucrania para
darle rápidamente por ejemplo en el caso
de españa para regularizar a migrantes
que estaban en situación irregular
migrantes ucranianos que estaban antes
de la guerra y que bueno el grupo como
poder que el lunes de salir un informe
sobre el impacto que pueda tener la
regularización de personas migrantes por
la fundación fue por causa que he
realizado este informe y se ha visto que
desde 2014 la cantidad de migrantes de
origen ucraniano ha ido en aumento y se
ha duplicado y en la parte de las
personas que son menores de edad la
mayoría son de niños entre 0 y 4 años
entonces estamos hablando de políticas
que bueno ahora en españa se va a
regularizar a estas personas que han
estado ya antes de la guerra en ucrania
se va a regularizar estas personas pero
estamos viendo realmente que las
políticas migratorias no han estado
realmente respondiendo como deben ser
consecuencias a todos los niveles de
adén de la guerra de ucrania que pone
también de relieve lo comenta antes
mareo genial tangente mente la
importancia de la defensa como un
europeo una cuestión ya antes evocada
pero que ahora se hace esencial sin
embargo los obstáculos para lograr la
pared en complejos cuales son esther
herrera bruselas
el jefe de la diplomacia europea eso se
aburre ya ha dicho en estos últimos días
que la invasión de ucrania ha acabado
con varios tabúes y uno de ellos es sin
duda la defensa este mes de marzo está
previsto que se apruebe la conocida como
brújula estratégica que entre otras
cuestiones prevé la creación de una
fuerza de acción rápida de cinco mil
soldados para que se puedan desplazar a
cualquier lugar esto es un hito pero que
ahora se hace más importante que nunca
la unión europea ha sido muy cuidadosa
en recordar que no pretende substituir a
la otan sino cooperar con ella y uno de
los miedos de los países del este es
justamente esto que tener una defensa
común no implique duplicidades con la
otan pero bruselas lo que quieres que es
que su papel geopolítico sea más
relevante no sustituir sino ser un actor
en el mundo a tener en cuenta y para
ello debe actuar con autonomía es más el
mundo ha cambiado de tal forma en estas
dos semanas que de la marca que no forma
parte de la defensa común europea ha
anunciado un referéndum para preguntar a
sus ciudadanos si quieren formar parte
de ella que era una cláusula que tenían
desde su entrada
la obligaba hoy hay obstáculos pero
muchas las residencias que antes
parecían insalvables en dos semanas se
han diluido
pues como decía como decía este luis
esta frase la escuché con la cob y no
que se están rompiendo varios tabúes en
la unión europea' a golpe de crisis
tanto pasó con la crisis sanitaria como
ahora con la local es verdad que eran
cosas que hace cinco años no estaban en
la agenda pero una cosa es hablar y otra
cosa es hacerlo claro porque ahora mismo
insisto con la emoción y con la
indignación humana normal ahora se dicen
muchas cosas pero vamos a ver si es
verdad porque la defensa europea por lo
menos de momento es una quimera total lo
único que han conseguido esto y que
quizá consiga es algo que donald trump
insistió y que putin ha conseguido es
decir que los país algunos países
europeos
aumenten su presupuesto de defensa es
restar pero vamos a ver cómo se puede
hablar de una de una defensa europea
unificada si la mayoría de los países
dependen de la otan en segundo lugar
como se puede hablar de
unidad
de defensa europea cuando cada país
incluso ahora está comprando aviones
norteamericanos en vez de comprar
aviones europeos y decir me parece
completamente
la feria de las declaraciones por el
momento no siquiera una industria
europea existiera una defensa europea se
requiere una industria europea y cada
uno ahora mismo está comprando los
aviones donde quiera y sobre todo en
eeuu que es él el que de momento y esto
no se trata de un partido de fútbol pero
está ganando la guerra comercial vamos
en los últimos minutos a ver si mano
genia querías puntualizar algo más yo
creo completamente de acuerdo con louis
esto no es hay un ganador
económicamente es eeuu y si queremos
tener independencia tenemos que tener
independencia en distintos flancos
no podemos ser absolutamente
independientes pero para hacer una
potencia mundial tenemos que
diversificar nuestros socios comerciales
en energía en defensa en salud en todas
las
claves es lo que es muy curioso la
situación que se ve con una guerra
porque de repente y que se me entiende
la expresión ahora maduro es nuestro
amigo ahora los iraníes son nuestros
amigos decir una situación de guerra de
repente remueve todas las fichas del
tablero y quienes antes eran sus
enemigos pasan a ser tus amigos
la frase estos son mis principios pero
si no le gustan no se preocupe tengo
otros sí pero bueno esto esto esto lo
demuestra y sobre todo es estados unidos
y no quiero existir sobre eeuu están
cambiando su estrategia es decir quién
ha hecho negociaciones que en venezuela
si eeuu que lo intentó hacer en secreto
pero bueno no se puede hacer en secreto
porque se sabe
esto lo que se está viendo fuera de
europa y lo que los europeos tienen que
darse cuenta también es decir yo insisto
cuando lo del armamento en europa hay 17
tipos de tanques en eeuu hay 1 es decir
hablar ahora de defensa europea está muy
bien quizá dentro de 50 años pero por lo
menos de momento hay que tener en cuenta
una cosa estamos en plena guerra y la
guerra se va a acabar cuando se acabe la
guerra sería era aún una paz no sabemos
cómo será pero todos los que han tomado
lo que dice que van a tomar medidas
ahora
muy importantes que van a medir para
atrás después van a decir no yo iba a
entrar en la otra pero allá no entró
porque como hay paz le abre un tara a
esther herrera tras dos semanas de
guerra se habla en los pasillos de las
instituciones comunitarias cómo puede
llegar el fin de esta guerra se confía
en la presión de las sanciones a putin
se espera una creciente presión
opositora dentro de rusia cuéntanos se
confía mucho en las sanciones sobre todo
la que ha permitido la mitad
la congelación de las reservas del banco
central ruso esto provoca que el rublo
caiga más del 20 como está ocurriendo
actualmente la inflación aumenta y la
bolsa sigue cerrada esto ahoga la
economía y rusia cada vez está más
aislada y junto con las sanciones a los
oligarcas rusos que apoyan a putin se
espera que esto pueda ejercer una
presión este es el objetivo además todos
los países occidentales insisten en que
abran las sanciones que esto no acaba
aquí lo hemos visto con la con la
prohibición de la importación del
petróleo y del gas por parte de eeuu y
de reino unido la idea es que todas las
medidas tengan el efecto deseado y esto
obliga a putin a negociar seriamente
confían en que la situación a largo
plazo sea insostenible para el país lo
que siempre se prevé es una guerra larga
pero en todo caso que sean los propios
oligarcas los que ejerzan presión no
tanto la ciudad y la ciudadanía ni la
oposición porque rusia no la tiene ha
acabado prácticamente con toda la
oposición la tiene encarcelada y
perseguida y por lo tanto acabar con el
régimen sólo puede ser solo de producir
desde dentro del régimen te confiar en
ello el régimen puede caer desde dentro
de rusia una frase que yo creo que la
clave la palabra clave es
interdependencia las extensiones son
importantes y tendrán un efecto pero
también la tendré las tendremos que
pagar así terminamos muchísimas gracias
a los tres a los cuatro con este desde
bruselas y a todos ustedes esperamos la
próxima semana quien en primera plana
gracias